This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的历课》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones.
有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界传递了一个信号：你可不好惹。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难成长的历课》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的检测，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
这需要一支互联网侦探大队来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《受困的爱》。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。记住是数字2百分之。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听此节目。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we are talking about a much requested topic and one that I think is highly personally relevant to me, understanding and overcoming our social anxiety. When we think about our 20s, there are a few generally universal experiences, I think we can all agree on and worrying about the opinions of others being very self-critical, concerned about whether we've embarrassed ourselves, our past mistakes, the times we've overshared or said the wrong thing. That is definitely one of them. It's definitely
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一集。今天，我们要讨论一个备受期待的话题，我认为这也与我自己息息相关：理解并克服我们的社交焦虑。当我们回想自己的二十岁时，有一些普遍的共同经历，我想我们都会认同，那就是过分在意别人的看法、极度自我批判、担心自己是否出丑、过去的错误、过度分享或说错话的时候。这绝对是其中之一。它绝对
a common thing that haunts us and keeps us up at night. There are so many experiences like this that I think live in our head rent-free, taking up this space that we perhaps could be using for other things, but also causing us to avoid certain situations or events out of fear of that really physical and emotional, even mental discomfort. And it can be really hard to wrangle with those thoughts and wrangle with that anxiety and bring it back into our control. This is particularly the case because, as we know, our brains are hardwired to seek the approval and the safety of others. think that perhaps we've done something that is wrong or we've done something that could be seen as awkward or cause us to be rejected or perceived negatively, our minds automatically
是一个困扰我们、让我们夜不能寐的常见问题。有太多这样的经历，我想它们免费住在我们的脑海里，占据了我们本可以用来做其他事情的空间，同时也导致我们因为害怕那种真正身体上、情感上甚至精神上的不适而避免某些情况或活动。要理清这些想法，应对这种焦虑，并重新把它掌握在我们的控制之下，可能会非常困难。之所以特别如此，是因为众所周知，我们的大脑生来就是为了寻求他人的认可和安全感。当我们认为自己可能做了错事，或者做了可能被视为尴尬的事情，或是导致我们被拒绝或被负面看待的事情时，我们的心思就会自动
set off an alarm system and it triggers a fear response that we come to know as social anxiety. And people feel this in so many areas of their lives when it comes to making new friends, to dating, job interviews, to lower. their inhibitions in front of new people. And I want you to know that you are not alone in that experience. I think any type of anxiety can cause us to feel very solitary and isolated because the only person whose reality we really understand is our own. So we tend to be hypercritical and hyper fixated on our interpretation of an event rather than our objective reality, one in which most people really aren't looking at us that closely. We are all very much selfish beings who spend a lot of
拉响警报系统，触发一种我们称之为社交焦虑的恐惧反应。人们在生活的许多方面都会感受到这一点，比如结交新朋友、约会、工作面试，或者在新人面前降低戒备。我想让你知道，在这段经历中你并不孤单。我认为任何类型的焦虑都会让我们感到非常孤独和孤立，因为我们真正理解的现实只有我们自己的。因此，我们往往对事件的解读过度批判和过度执着，而不是基于客观现实——在这个现实中，大多数人其实并没有那么密切地关注我们。我们都是非常自私的人，花了很多
time ruminating on our faults, wondering who may be thinking about us when no one is because we're all in the same boat. So today I really want to discuss some of the ways that we can control our social anxiety or at least understand it better and make peace with those feelings and not let them hold us back from the joy, the excitement, the surprises of our 20s. We are going to examine why we feel socially anxious and what actually is perhaps a deeper social phobia. Where does that fear come from? We'll also look at the major cognitive distortions that try and convince us that we are awkward, that we are embarrassing or socially inept, and why those distortions are false. there is also such an interesting relationship between overthinking, perfectionism and social anxiety
时间反思自己的缺点，想知道当没人注意到我们时，是否有人在想我们，因为我们都在同一条船上。所以今天我真的很想讨论一些方法，帮助我们控制社交焦虑，或者至少更好地理解它，与这些感觉和平相处，不让它们阻挡我们去感受二十多岁的快乐、兴奋和惊喜。我们将探讨为什么我们会感到社交焦虑，以及什么实际上可能是更深层的社交恐惧症。这种恐惧从何而来？我们还将审视主要的认知扭曲，它们试图说服我们自己很尴尬、很出丑或社交无能，并探讨为什么这些扭曲是错误的。此外，过度思考、完美主义和社交焦虑之间也存在着一种非常有趣的关系
that is rarely discussed and I think it relates to a lot of people that I speak to and also my own situation as well. So how can we use that understanding, use that broader knowledge of our social anxiety to reclaim our authenticity, to reclaim our confidence and not live in that shadow of someone else's opinion or our perception of someone else's opinion of us. There is so much to cover as someone who still remembers every embarrassing thing that has happened to me since I was a child. The time I tripped and fell in front of the stairs of someone I really liked or the time I got really drunk at a work event and said weird things to my boss. I'm here with you, but I also have some of the psychology and the hidden explanations and also the advice for why we all feel this way
，但这一点很少被讨论，我认为它与许多和我交过流的人以及我自己的情况都有关。那么，我们如何利用这种理解，利用对社交焦虑更广泛的认知来找回我们的真实自我，找回我们的自信，不再活在别人的意见或我们对别人如何看待我们的感知的阴影之下呢？有太多内容需要涵盖了，作为一个至今仍记得自我懂事以来发生在自己身上的每一件尴尬事情的人——比如我曾经在自己非常喜欢的人的台阶前绊倒摔跤，或者我在公司活动中喝得酩酊大醉，对老板说了些怪话——我与你们感同身受，但我也有一些心理学原理、隐藏的解释，以及关于为什么我们有时都会有这种感觉的建议
sometimes and why it is not only natural but something that we can come to learn to control. So all of that and more. Without further ado, let us get into the psychology behind our social anxiety. Every single one of us is going to experience occasional moments of embarrassment, of cringe, of anxiety around social interactions, wondering whether we overshed, whether we said something we don't remember, did that person like me? And all of those things are, I think, very common things that I've experienced myself, things that have sometimes really got in the way of me connecting with people deeply or feeling like I wanted to kind of curl up into a ball and hide
，以及为什么这不仅是很自然的事，而且是我们能够学会控制的事情。所有这些以及更多内容。闲话少说，让我们进入社交焦虑背后的心理学。我们每个人都会偶尔经历尴尬、难为情、对社交互动感到焦虑的时刻，琢磨着自己是不是分享得太多了，是不是说了什么不记得的话，那个人喜欢我吗？所有这些，我认为都是非常常见的经历，我自己也曾经历过，这些事情有时确实阻碍了我与他人进行深度的连接，或者让我觉得自己想蜷缩成一团藏起来
away and never speak to anyone ever again. I think that occasional hyper focus on our ability to be perceived and therefore to be judged feels like one that is quite a heavy, burden to bear, but also one that is felt by quite a few people out there. A part of these experiences and the feelings of being self-conscious or over-analyzing a social situation from time to time is really normal, despite it being uncomfortable. This reaction is a function of our environment and our evolution. And simply put, historically our survival was dependent on group acceptance. We needed to be part of the tribe for things like food, shelter and security. And if we were outcast, it was essentially a bit of a death sentence. So this necessitated an innate
，再也不和任何人说话了。我认为，偶尔过度关注自己被他人感知、进而被他人评判的能力，感觉是一个相当沉重的负担，但也是相当多的人所感受到的。尽管这些经历和感觉让人感到不舒服，但感到自我意识过强或偶尔过度分析社交情况是完全正常的，这其实是我们的环境和进化的一个功能。简而言之，从历史上看，我们的生存取决于群体的接受。我们需要成为部落的一部分来获取食物、住所和安全等东西。如果我们被驱逐，基本上就等同于判了死刑。因此，这就需要有一种内在的
recognition of the opinions and the perspective of the group and also our reputation within it. So when we act in a way that we think brings attention to us or could put us on the out or garner negativity or rejection, what that triggers is a lot of fear or anxiety that is highly instinctual. that uncomfortable feeling, that sense of social anxiety is meant to protect us as annoying as it is. It's meant to warn us not to do that again and provide an emotionally salient experience that will keep us in line. And that evolutionary instinct that has come from a place of survival, it has lingered with us. And it continues to create situations and feelings that make us feel uncomfortable, that make us question our worth. and question whether other people like us, what their judgments of us are.
对群体意见和观点的认可，以及我们在其中的声誉的认知。因此，当我们做出自己认为会引起他人注意、或者可能使我们被边缘化、招致负面评价或拒绝的行为时，就会引发大量高度本能的恐惧或焦虑。这种不适感、这种社交焦虑感，尽管很烦人，但其目的是为了保护我们。它是为了警告我们不要再犯，并提供一种能让我们循规蹈矩的情感深刻体验。而这种出于生存本能的进化冲动，至今仍然挥之不去。它继续制造着让我们感到不适的情境和感受，让我们质疑自己的价值
There's a really important distinction here, though, between occasional feelings of being embarrassed or self-conscious and a genuine diagnosable social anxiety disorder, otherwise known as a social phobia. And really the distinction here is based on severity and frequency. So social anxiety disorder is definitely not uncommon. it's actually the third most common mental health condition behind depression and substance use disorders and the most common form of anxiety.
，质疑别人是否喜欢我们，他们对我们的评价如何。不过，这里有一个非常重要的区别，那就是偶尔感到尴尬或不自然，与真正可诊断的社交焦虑症（也称为社交恐惧症）之间的区别。这里的真正区别在于严重程度和频率。因此，社交焦虑症绝对并不少见。它实际上是仅次于抑郁症和物质使用障碍的第三大最常见心理健康状况，也是最常见的一种焦虑症。
So it impacts between, I think, like 6 to 10%, depending on your estimates, of people worldwide. And those numbers, those numbers are huge. What this says is that almost one in 10 of us are walking around with an intense discomfort and even fear towards social situations. And inherent to that is this worry of being judged, of being humiliated, of being outcast. Because we really do care about the opinions of others even when we try not to. And what this can lead us to do is to avoid certain situations where we might be forced with, you know, forced to interact with people we don't know or maybe, you know, situations
因此，据估计，它影响了全球约6%到10%的人口。这个数字是非常巨大的。这说明，我们当中几乎十分之一的人都在承受着对社交情境的强烈不适甚至恐惧。而这其中固有的就是害怕被评判、被羞辱、被排挤的担忧。因为我们确实在意别人的看法，即使我们极力试图不在意。而这可能会导致我们避开某些情境，在这些情境中我们可能会被迫，你知道的，被迫与不认识的人互动，或者可能是，你知道的，那些
where we don't know what to say, where we're uncomfortable, unprepared. Perhaps we kind of have to stand alone in the corner of the party, like waiting and awkwardly looking around for someone you know, literally the worst feeling ever. But this social anxiety, especially when it's linked to a social anxiety disorder, it causes us to be particularly fearful or anxious towards things like attending parties or social gatherings, going places where we don't, know anyone in having to meet new people or start a conversation. Another big one is things like
我们不知道该说什么、感到不舒服、毫无准备的情境。也许我们不得不孤零零地站在派对的角落里，像是在等待着，尴尬地环顾四周寻找你认识的人，这简直是世界上最糟糕的感觉。但是这种社交焦虑，尤其是当它与社交焦虑症联系在一起时，会让我们对参加派对或社交聚会、去那些我们不认识任何人的地方、不得不认识新的人或开始一段对话等事情感到特别恐惧或焦虑。另一个大问题是诸如
public speaking or speaking up in public settings like in a classroom or during a work presentation and then in more extreme cases. Some people can have such an intense cognitive and emotional reaction that they struggle doing things like eating or drinking in front of other people or using public spaces or public restrooms. The main triggers are situations in which which we acknowledge that we can be perceived and that something about our behavior might reveal these parts of us that we are convinced of but that we are trying to keep invisible. Those parts of us that we don't like and we're worried what people will think if they see them, that we are a fraud, that we are awkward, that we have nothing to say.
公众演讲，或者在教室或工作汇报等公共场合公开表态，而在更极端的情况下。有些人甚至会有强烈的认知和情感反应，以至于他们在别人面前吃东西、喝水，或者使用公共场所、公共洗手间都变得十分困难。主要的触发因素是我们意识到自己能够被他人感知，并且我们的某种行为可能会暴露出我们深信不疑却又极力想要隐藏的那些部分。那些我们不喜欢、并担心别人看到后会怎么想的自己——比如我们是个骗子、我们很尴尬、我们无话可说。
And if people were to find out about this kind of secret side of us, we believe it would be the end of the world. We believe that everything around us would come crumbling down. And we respond to this possibility with anxiety. And anxiety is essentially a fear response, particularly anticipatory anxiety, where we project our fears onto a future situation in anticipation of an event or a situation that might leave us feeling a bit unstable or a little bit uncertain. And the logic, the kind of illogic almost goes that if we can anticipate what might go wrong,
如果人们发现了我们这种秘密的一面，我们相信这就是世界末日。我们相信周围的一切都会崩溃。而我们对这种可能性做出的反应就是焦虑。焦虑本质上是一种恐惧反应，尤其是预期性焦虑，即我们将恐惧投射到未来的某个情境中，预判某个事件或情况可能会让我们感到有些不稳定或有些不确定。其逻辑，或者说近乎不合逻辑的想法是，如果我们能预料到什么可能会出错
where we might misstep, we can put a plan in place to be prepared for the worst case scenario. And also our brain tells us that the easiest way to minimize the worst case scenario is by avoidance. If we actively avoid social situations, we don't have to feel anxious. And if our goal is to avoid anxiety, then that is a very effective way of going about it. But it's also, unfortunately, not very sustainable, nor is it particularly health. given that deep social connection and even casual everyday interaction is really vital for maintaining our mood and our well-being. Also, whilst avoidance temporarily makes us feel better, it just makes us more fearful in the future because we never give ourselves the opportunity to prove that nasty,
，我们在哪里可能会失误，我们就可以制定一个计划来为最坏的情况做好准备。同时，我们的大脑也告诉我们，将最坏情况的影响降到最低的最简单方法就是逃避。如果我们积极逃避社交场合，我们就不用感到焦虑了。如果我们的目标是逃避焦虑，那么这确实是一个非常有效的方法。但遗憾的是，它既不太可持续，也不是特别健康。考虑到深度的社交连接甚至是日常的随性互动对于维持我们的情绪和幸福感至关重要。而且，虽然逃避暂时让我们感觉好受一些，但它只会让我们在未来感到更加恐惧，因为我们从来没有给自己机会去证明那个讨厌的、
negative voice in our head wrong. We really cannot shy away from our need for deep vulnerability. and meaningful relationships. But we're just worried about the judgments of others. And because of that worry, we never challenge the fear. The fear maintains itself. We find ourselves back at square one. And you know, everyone's going to have their own thoughts. Sometimes people will not like you. But I think very truly, no one is thinking about you as much as you are thinking about yourself. We are innately, very egocentric creatures, we are all too busy examining our own behavior, thinking about what we need to have for dinner, thinking about our to-do list, thinking about our relationships, the things that are bothering us to really judge others. And we're going to talk more about that fallacy in a second.
我们脑海中的负面声音是错的。我们真的无法回避对深度脆弱感和有意义关系的渴望。但我们只是担心别人的评判。正因为这种担忧，我们从未挑战过恐惧。恐惧便自我维持。我们发现自己又回到了原点。你知道的，每个人都会有自己的想法。有时人们会不喜欢你。但我真心认为，没有人在意你想你自己那么多。我们生来就是非常以自我为中心的生物，我们都太忙于审视自己的行为，思考我们需要吃什么晚餐，思考我们的待办事项清单，思考我们的人际关系，思考那些困扰我们的事情，根本无暇去评判别人。我们稍后会更多地讨论这个谬论。
But the other way that our social anxiety can show up is through what we call post-event rumination. So this occurs when we are obsessively critical of our social performance or behavior following some event or interaction. So post-event rumination is when you find yourself really brooding, overthinking, every single gesture, tonal change, laugh, interaction. You might focus on any of the mistakes you think you have made. But you also may imagine scenarios that didn't happen, like walking out of a room and people laughing at you the moment that you left or being criticized or judged. Often, these ruminating thoughts, this tendency, will become part of a cycle that maintains our social anxiety by promoting that future avoidance. You worry that you embarrassed
但是，社交焦虑表现出来的另一种方式是通过我们所说的“事件后反刍”（post-event rumination）。这发生在我们在某个事件或互动之后，对自己的社交表现或行为进行强迫性的批判时。因此，事件后反刍是指你会陷入沉思，过度思考每一个手势、语调的变化、笑声、互动。你可能会把注意力集中在你认为自己犯下的任何错误上。但你也可能会想象一些并未发生的情景，比如你刚走出房间，大家就在你离开的那一刻嘲笑你，或者你受到了批评和评判。通常，这些反刍的想法和这种倾向会成为一个循环，通过促进未来的回避来维持我们的社交焦虑。你担心自己出了丑
yourself, which causes you to run through every detail of the event to provide yourself with self-assurance. But the more time you spend thinking about your behavior, the more mistakes you see or the more mistakes you create. And these are called false memories, which can become implanted in our mind when we repeatedly revise a memory, when we repeatedly go back to it. And that just causes us to, unfortunately,
，这导致你把事件的每一个细节都在脑海里过一遍，以寻求自我安慰。然而，你花在思考自己行为上的时间越多，你看到的错误就越多，或者你创造出的错误就越多。这些被称为虚假记忆，当我们反复修正一个记忆、反复回到它上面时，它们就会植入我们的脑海。而这只会不幸地导致我们
worry even more than we need to. One situation where I see this a lot is after a night of heavy drinking, where our social anxiety kind of combines with the after effects of alcohol, and can cause us to spiral even further until, you know, you're promising yourself you'll never drink again or refusing to look at your phone, wondering when someone will text you to say how embarrassing you were or tell you something that you did. This is because alcohol in particular activate some of those brain regions that are already being triggered by our social anxiety. So experts have theorized that anxiety is related to using alcohol to overcome social anxiety.
比实际需要地更加担忧。我经常看到这种情况的一个场景是在大量饮酒的夜晚之后，此时我们的社交焦虑与酒精的后劲结合在一起，会导致我们陷入更深的恶性循环，直到，你知道的，你发誓再也不喝酒了，或者拒绝看手机，心里纳闷什么时候会有人发短信来说你有多尴尬，或者告诉你你做了什么。这是因为酒精会特别激活我们大脑中那些已经被社交焦虑触发的区域。因此，专家们推论，焦虑与利用酒精来克服社交焦虑有关。
So alcohol as a drug will initially help you feel better. You will feel more relaxed. You will feel more calm because it releases this neurotransmitter called GABA. And GABA slows everything down and it lessens the ability of our nerves to give and receive messages, meaning less overthinking, less inhibition, less nerves. But in the morning, when the alcohol wears off, our brains need to rebalance all of the neurotransmit is working on our mind. And so it releases this neurotransmitter called glutamate
所以酒精作为一种药物，最初会让你感觉好一些。你会感到更放松。你会感到更平静，因为它释放了一种叫做GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）的神经递质。GABA会减慢一切事物的运转，并减弱神经传递和接收信息的能力，这意味着更少的过度思考、更少的抑制、更少的紧张。但在早晨，当酒精药效过去后，我们的大脑需要重新平衡大脑中运作的所有神经递质。于是它释放了一种叫做谷氨酸（glutamate）的神经递质
to kind of counterbalance the excessive amount of gabber that the alcohol is triggered. And glutamate does the opposite of gamma. It excites our brain. It spikes our anxiety. And it also reactivates things like memory and cognition. So that blissful, calm and ignorance is gone. And suddenly we are right back in the social anxiety spiral,
来对冲酒精所引发的大量GABA。而谷氨酸的作用与GABA相反。它会兴奋我们的大脑。它会使我们的焦虑飙升。它还会重新激活记忆和认知等功能。于是那种极乐、平静和无知消失了。突然之间，我们又回到了社交焦虑的漩涡中，
except even more so now because we have this unbalanced kind of chemical pattern in our brain to deal with, which is making us more susceptible to ruminating on those embarrassing moments and how we behaved in front of others, despite it being highly, highly likely, that those people do not remember much more than you do. So why is it that other people's opinions take on so much importance in our lives? Well, aside from that evolutionary explanation we offered earlier, a lot of us develop what we call cognitive distortions, whereby we see social situations as being more meaningful than they actually are. And therefore, we generalise that our behaviour in those situations should take on more importance. We should examine them more closely.
只不过现在情况更糟了，因为我们需要应付大脑中这种不平衡的化学模式，这让我们更容易对那些尴尬时刻以及自己在他人面前的表现进行反刍，尽管事实上，那些人记住的可能并不比你多多少。那么，为什么别人的意见在我们的生活中占据如此重要的地位呢？好吧，除了我们之前给出的进化论解释之外，我们很多人还发展出了所谓的认知扭曲，即我们认为社交情境比实际情况更有意义。因此，我们概括认为我们在这些情境中的行为应该具有更重要的意义。我们应该更仔细地审视它们。
It's interesting because as we spoke about before, we are quite egocentric beings, because the only person's reality we truly understand is our own. And so we can't peer into someone else's mind and confirm or deny their opinion of us. We can't see ourselves the way others see us. We have to rely on our own judgments, which are often very skewed. And that has two consequences for feeling socially anxious. Number one, firstly, because we never know what others are thinking, this creates uncertainty. and that uncertainty causes us to catastrophize and to expect the worse, because if we are prepared
有趣的是，正如我们之前所说，我们是相当以自我为中心的生物，因为我们唯一真正理解的现实只有我们自己的。所以我们无法窥探别人的内心，来证实或否定他们对我们的看法。我们无法像别人看到我们那样看到自己。我们必须依赖自己的判断，而这些判断往往严重偏颇。这给感到社交焦虑带来了两个后果。第一，首先，由于我们永远不知道别人在想什么，这就会产生不确定性，
for the worst case scenario, any other scenario won't be as terrifying. Even if we are horrifically rejected, at least we're prepared for this. At least that's what our anxiety has convinced us. We are already aware of that perception, and it makes us feel like we can cope if that is actually the outcome. Secondly, we have no context for how other people, people are feeling, specifically how they're probably feeling the same way. We think that it must just be us, that we just must be the most awkward, embarrassing person. This stuff never happens to other people. Everyone else has so much confidence because how can we confirm that others are feeling the same way or experiencing things as intensely as we are? And so the experience becomes really
而这种不确定性会导致我们灾难化思维并预期最坏的情况，因为如果我们为最坏的情况做好了准备，任何其他情况就不会那么可怕。即使我们遭到可怕的拒绝，至少我们做好了准备。至少我们的焦虑是这样说服我们的。我们已经意识到那种感知，这让我们觉得如果这真的发生了，我们也能应对。其次，我们对于别人的感受没有任何背景信息，尤其是他们可能也有同样的感受。我们认为这一定只是我们自己，我们一定是最尴尬、最出丑的人。这种事情从来不会发生在大多数人身上。其他人都有那么多的自信，因为我们怎么能证实别人也有同样的感受，或者有和我们一样强烈的体验呢？因此，这种体验变得非常
isolating and sometimes talking about a particular situation in which we felt like we have misstepped can actually sting even more. So we bury this thought, this negative reaction in overthinking and internalizing. There's two other cognitive distortions that we are socially anxious people can fall into. Sometimes we see ourselves more negatively than we are in reality. It's what we call a negative self-concept where we think that our behavior must be so much worse than we imagined that what we said might actually be offensive and that we just didn't know it. We have trouble seeing ourselves as good people as someone who is fun and who people want to be around and who people really do like. And I think if you're an anxious person,
孤立，有时谈论一个让我们觉得失控的特定情况甚至会更加刺痛。所以我们将这种想法、这种负面反应埋藏在过度思考和内化之中。我们这些有社交焦虑的人还会陷入另外两种认知扭曲。有时我们对自己负面的看法超过了现实。这就是所谓的“负面自我概念”，我们认为自己的行为一定比想象的要糟糕得多，我们说的话可能真的具有攻击性，而我们自己却浑然不知。我们很难把自己看作好人，看作一个有趣、大家都想与之相处并且真正喜欢的人。我想如果你是一个焦虑的人，
you already are highly sensitive to social cues from others. And if you have this baseline way of seeing yourself, any tiny suggestion you pick up from someone's behaviour, will act to confirm your bias. It will act to confirm this negative self-concept, despite it being real or not. That person may have been having a really rough day. They may be worrying about their own insecurities. They may be just as anxious as you. However, you can't see those explanations because you have been misled by negative self-talk, over-analysis, and your own self-perception of your actions. I think it's important to remember. Just, Just because you feel anxious, just because you feel awkward, just because you feel embarrassed,
你本身就已经对别人的社交线索高度敏感。如果你有这种底层的自我认知方式，你从别人的行为中捕捉到的任何微小暗示，都会用来证实你的偏见。它会用来证实这种负面的自我概念，无论它是真是假。那个人那天可能过得很艰难。他们可能在担心自己的不安全感。他们可能和你一样焦虑。然而，你看不到这些解释，因为你已经被消极的自我对话、过度分析以及你对自己行为的自我认知给误导了。我认为记住这一点很重要。仅仅因为你感到焦虑，仅仅因为你感到尴尬，仅仅因为你感到羞愧
doesn't mean that those things are true. Your emotions are just your emotions. Your perceptions are just your perceptions. They are not character descriptions. They are not always reality. What you did is probably not as terrible as you think it was. That thing you're remitting on or obsessing about, it's unlikely anyone else even remembers it. And also if a friend came to you with the same situation, you would probably not think twice about it
，并不意味着这些事情就是真的。你的情绪只是你的情绪。你的感知也只是你的感知。它们不是性格描述。它们并不总是现实。你所做的事情可能没有你想象的那么糟糕。你一直在反思或执着的那件事，其他人很可能根本不记得了。而且，如果一个朋友带着同样的情况来找你，你可能根本不会多想
and you would see it very clearly from an objective point of view and tell them, you know, it's not that bad, it's not even close to being bad, it's kind of all made up in your head. And the same goes for the situation you're worried about. A lot of what we take from a situation is not based on reality, it's based on our opinion. The second cognitive distortion is that everyone is looking at you. It links back to the above. We are the center of our own universe. And so we notice when people are focusing on us and we rarely remember those times when they weren't. Good news for us though is that the opinions of other people are fortunately none of our business. And if they are spending all that time
，并且你会从客观的角度非常清晰地看待它，告诉他们，你知道的，这没那么糟，离糟糕还差得远呢，这纯粹是你脑子里的胡思乱想。你担心的那种情况也是如此。我们从一个情境中提取的大部分内容都不是基于现实，而是基于我们的意见。第二种认知扭曲是“每个人都在看着你”。这与上面提到的有关。我们是自己宇宙的中心。所以我们会注意到别人把焦点放在我们身上的时刻，却很少记得他们没有这样做的时刻。不过对我们来说的好消息是，幸运的是，别人的看法根本不管我们的事。如果他们花那么多时间——
we think they are, judging, talking, considering our actions or our behavior, that is causing more harm to them than it is causing us. And really, what's the worst thing their opinions can do. If they decide to go on some reputational tirade or say something behind your back, that looks a lot worse on them than us, especially if we stay true to our authenticity and our good nature and we kind of keep our head above the throw. I also think we need to contemplate the following hypothetical. Can you remember the last time you judge someone? And why did you judge them? What did you say? Was it something about their outfit, something they said? And how much time did you actually think about it? I'm guessing it couldn't have been for more than a few seconds,
也就是我们以为的那些时间——来评判、谈论、考量我们的行动或行为，这对他们造成的伤害其实比对我们造成的伤害更大。说真的，他们的意见又能做得了什么最坏的事呢？如果他们决定进行某种声誉诋毁，或者在背后说你的坏话，那只会让他们看起来比我们更糟糕，特别是如果我们坚持真实的自我和善良的本性，并且保持清醒高傲的头脑。我还认为我们需要思考以下这个假设。你还记得你上一次评判别人是什么时候吗？你为什么要评判他们？你说了什么？是关于他们的穿着，还是他们说的话？你实际上花了多少时间去想这件事？我猜绝对不会超过几秒钟
maybe minutes, because our brains are constantly thinking about the next thing. We only have such limited cognitive space to plan our lives, to worry about what our relationships are doing, to worry about ourselves. And that's really where everyone's focus is going. I think we need to remind ourselves that your social anxiety is lying to you, but it's also trying to protect you. by overgeneralizing, by distorting your reality, or magnifying what are very small moments as a valuable way to kind of keep you in check. And counteracting those negative thoughts when they pop into your mind is really important if you want to live the life you want to live.
，最多几分钟，因为我们的大脑总是在思考下一件事。我们只有这么有限的认知空间来规划生活，担心人际关系的发展，担心我们自己。这才是所有人注意力的所在。我认为我们需要提醒自己：你的社交焦虑在对你撒谎，但它也试图保护你。通过过度概括、扭曲现实，或者把非常微小的时刻无限放大，作为一种让你保持警惕的有效方式。当你脑海中闪过这些负面想法时，去对抗它们对于你想过上自己想要的生活至关重要。
If you want to live in your authenticity and make the most out of your social experiences. So how do we do that? How do we reclaim the narrative around how people choose? choose to see us and why their opinion really shouldn't matter as much as we think it does. Well, we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers,
如果你想活出真实的自我，充分利用你的社交经历。那么我们该怎么做呢？我们如何夺回关于人们如何选择看待我们、以及为什么他们的意见其实不应该像我们想象的那样重要的叙事主导权？好吧，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%——那是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、
researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl.
研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。记住是数字2百分之。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要招惹乡下女孩。
You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me?
你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝对不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女朋友们》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，怎么会发生这种事在我身上？
The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们。相信我，宝贝》。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人的时候？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack
每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill），大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。说清楚点，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备聊聊快克，但为了让大家知道，我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
so I'm starting to see there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now so Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year for black people
所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆到桌面上来了，所以感谢你把那句话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了
Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years for black people in American history Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcasts
真的吗？是的，对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客
or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难成长的历课》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
而我们仍在追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·ب恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app.
绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难成长的历课》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用。
Search learn the hard way and listen now. It always fascinates me how much we allow others to be fallible, to be imperfect, human beings, how much we're willing to overlook and laugh with them at their mistakes and hold off our judgment. But we never give ourselves permission to do the same. You know, if our friend tells us something embarrassing that happened to them, we don't feel it as deeply as they do because we can see it objectively, but also we let them be those kinds of people. We enjoy that they are not perfect,
搜索《艰难成长的历课》（Learn the Hard Way）并立即收听。我总是对一件事感到着迷：我们如何允许他人犯错、成为不完美的人类，我们有多愿意去忽视并与他们一起嘲笑他们的错误，同时克制住我们的评判。但我们从不给自己同样的许可。你知道，如果我们的朋友告诉我们他们身上发生了什么尴尬的事情，我们不会像他们那样感同身受，因为我们可以客观地看待它，而且我们允许他们做那样的人。我们喜欢他们并不完美，
but we have to be perfect. We always have to be on our best behavior. We always have to be warm and charming and funny and so on. So it's no surprise, I think, that many of us who are anxious in other ways also find that we have a relationship to perfectionism and also a relationship to a tendency to overthink. There's been some really comprehensive studies,
但我们却必须完美。我们必须时刻表现得最好。我们必须时刻热情、迷人、幽默等等。因此，我认为这毫不奇怪，许多在其他方面感到焦虑的人也会发现，他们与完美主义有关联，同时也倾向于过度思考。有一些非常全面的研究
on this correlation whereby highly perfectionistic individuals have an increased probability and level of social anxiety. And on a very fundamental level, that makes a lot of sense. Perfectionist individuals tend to have extremely high personal standards and they critically evaluate every little mistake they make. Much like our social anxiety, wanting to come up perfect in every situation, perfectionism also causes us to set very unrealistic standards for our performance in every areas of life. And whilst we typically think of that in terms of things like academics and professional success, our brains don't shut off that perfectionist part of us for one activity and keep it on for another. So given our underlying inferiority and sense of inferiority
探讨了这种相关性，即高度完美主义的个体具有更高的社交焦虑概率和水平。从非常基础的层面上讲，这非常合乎情理。完美主义者往往有极高的个人标准，并且会批判性地评估他们犯下的每一个小错误。就像我们的社交焦虑想要在每种情况下都表现完美一样，完美主义也会导致我们对自己在生活各个领域的表现设定非常不切实际的标准。虽然我们通常从学业和职业成功等方面来考虑这一点，但我们的大脑不会为了某一项活动而关闭完美主义的那一部分，却为另一项活动保持开启。因此，鉴于我们作为完美主义者根深蒂固的自卑感和自卑意识
as perfectionist and our tendency to view ourselves negatively, often what that also means is that we're going to criticize ourselves more harshly when we perceive we don't meet certain standards that are set by our society, specifically when it comes to social situations. And much like that avoidance we were talking about before, often that comes out as if I don't know how I'm going to be in this situation, if I don't have a game plan, if I'm not sure, I may as well avoid it because in those situations, they could provide an opportunity for me to be exposed and to feel shame and self-consciousness. And that really mixes in with our social anxiety and it exacerbates all of that awkwardness and avoidance
以及我们看待自己的负面倾向，这通常也意味着当我们觉得没有达到社会设定的某些标准时，我们会对自己进行更严厉的批判，尤其是在社交场合中。就像我们之前谈到的逃避一样，通常表现出来的结果是：如果我不知道自己在这种情况下会表现如何，如果我没有应对计划，如果我不确定，我不如选择逃避，因为这些情况可能会给我提供一个暴露自己、感到羞耻和自我意识过强的机会。这与我们的社交焦虑完美地融合在一起，并加剧了我们之前讨论过的所有尴尬和逃避。
that we discussed before. And then there's the overthinking. Anyone who said the wrong thing or done something that they think was embarrassing in front of others will know the feeling of being haunted by that memory for weeks to come. That like cringe when you're like lying in bed and you remember that one time you did that one thing and it's like that is the entire universe at that moment. That is all you can think about. Feeling the need to relive it again and again despite the sting is such a common experience.
然后就是过度思考。任何在别人面前说过错话或做过自认为尴尬事情的人，都会体会到被那个记忆纠缠数周的感受。那种尴尬感就像你躺在床上时，突然想起那次你做过的那件事，那一刻它仿佛成了整个宇宙。那是你唯一能想到的事情。那种不顾刺痛感、非要一遍又一遍地重温它的冲动，是一种非常普遍的体验。
It's like a wound that we won't let heal because we fall into this faulty belief that if we contemplate this situation over and over again, somehow we'll find some closure or the pain will lessen. I always think about the metaphor of it's like glass being washed around in the sea that eventually comes sand. You know, if we keep washing over this memory in our mind, slowly will become smaller and smaller. The more we force ourselves to feel our embarrassment, the more we might become immune to it. Or maybe on the other hand, we punish ourselves with it in order to prevent situations like the one we just lived through. Here's the truth though. That tendency to overthink will only further entrench that cycle of anticipatory anxiety, avoidance,
这就好比一个我们不让它愈合的伤口，因为我们陷入了一种错误信念：如果我们一遍又一遍地思考这种情况，我们总会找到某种释怀，或者痛苦会减轻。我经常想到这样一个比喻：它就像海浪中冲刷的玻璃，最终会变成沙子。你知道，如果我们一直在脑海中反复回味这段记忆，它慢慢就会变得越来越小。我们越是强迫自己去感受尴尬，就越有可能对它产生免疫力。或者从另一方面来说，我们用它来惩罚自己，以此来避免再次经历刚才那种情况。然而，事实是这样的。这种过度思考的倾向只会进一步加深预期性焦虑、逃避、
post-event rumination, and spiraling. It's really difficult to feel like our social anxiety is under our control, but also we're not aiming for the complete absence of those thoughts, or to suppress those feelings entirely. I think that we're be equally as maladaptive as social avoidance itself, because some part of us does need to have that healthy level of perception of others' feelings and how to respond to their social cues and receptiveness to other people to be socially adaptable humans. But when we let that fear hold us back from genuine connection or the possibility for connection because we are scared of what other people might think, I really believe we miss it.
事件发生后的反刍以及恶性循环。要觉得我们的社交焦虑在我们的控制之下真的很困难，但同时我们也不是为了完全消除这些想法，或者完全压抑这些感受。我认为这和社交逃避本身一样会带来不适应，因为我们内心的一部分确实需要对别人的感受有健康水平的感知，知道如何回应他们的社交暗示以及对其他人的接受度，从而成为能够在社交中适应的人。但当我们让这种恐惧阻碍我们建立真诚的连接，或者阻碍连接的可能性，因为我们害怕别人可能会怎么想，我真的相信我们错过了
out on a lot of the beautiful experiences and surprises in life, even when sometimes they're a little bit uncomfortable. So what we want to do is replace that perfectionism with authenticity. Instead of being committed to impressing other people, remain committed to behaving in alignment with who you are, not what other people expect you to be. So what does that look like? authenticity is really our capacity to identify and be loyal to our true selves, even the things we don't love, to be comfortable with the ways we're different, regardless of all the things society and others and your social anxiety is going to say. I think it's also about recognizing that we are incredibly multi-dimensional people. There is no one else like us, and our love for ourselves
生活中许多美好的体验和惊喜，即使有时它们会让人感到有点不舒服。所以我们要做的，是用真实来取代完美主义。不要执着于给别人留下深刻印象，而是要始终坚持与真正的自己保持一致的行为，而不是活成别人期望的样子。那么这具体是怎样的呢？真实其实是我们识别并忠于真实自我的能力，甚至是那些我们不喜欢的方面，去坦然接受我们与众不同的地方，不管社会、其他人以及你的社交焦虑会怎么说。我认为这还意味着我们要认识到我们是极其多维的人。世界上没有第二个我们，我们对自己的爱
isn't dependent on someone else's acceptance of who we believe we are and our true selves. I think really at its core authenticity comes from a place of confidence, even if that confidence isn't real, even if we need to fake it till we make it for a while. Reinforcing though that it doesn't matter if other people don't like you because you like yourself. It doesn't matter if you make mistakes because mistakes make really good stories. and it really doesn't matter if other people think you're weird or awkward because you know who you are, their opinion is very much fleeting, you don't have to engage with them if that's how they're going to choose to treat you and you're going to choose to love those parts of you regardless.
并不取决于别人是否接受我们所认为的自己和真实的自我。我认为，真实的核心实际上来自于自信，即使这种自信并不是真的，即使我们需要“假装直到拥有它”一段时间。不过，我们要强化的一点是：别人不喜欢你并不重要，因为你喜欢自己。你犯错并不重要，因为错误能化为很好的故事。别人觉得你奇怪或笨拙也真的不重要，因为你知道自己是谁，他们的看法转瞬即逝，如果他们打算这样对待你，你并不需要去迎合他们，而你无论如何都会选择爱自己的那些部分。
You know, if someone decides to make a snap judgment of your character based on one moment or one instant, that says a lot more about them than it says about you. Really, at the end of the day, it says so much about it. their close-mindedness, but also their insecurity, that they're looking to minimize your acceptance of yourself to feel better about themselves. These reminders, when implemented regularly in the face of socially anxious thoughts, really recondition our brain to see social situations not as scary or deserving of a fear response, but as opportunities in which we can prove ourselves and further deepen our character.
你知道，如果有人决定根据某一刻或某个瞬间对你的性格妄下断言，这更多地说明了他们自己，而不是你。说到底，这充分说明了他们的思想闭塞，同时也说明了他们的不安全感，他们通过贬低你对自己的接纳来让自己感觉好过一点。这些提醒如果在面对社交焦虑的想法时经常实施，真的会重新调理我们的大脑，把社交场景不再视为可怕的或理应引发恐惧反应的东西，而是视为我们可以证明自己并进一步深化品格的机会。
This might still be accompanied by a little bit of anxiety. That's normal. That's totally natural to feel some nerves. But the thing about anxiety is that it feels a lot like excitement. And we can use our thoughts to treat that feeling like energy and motivation rather than as something to fear. You know, tell yourself before an event, before you need to meet new people. that you're excited by that feeling, that you're excited by the possibility,
这可能仍然会伴随着一点点焦虑。这很正常。感到紧张是完全自然的事情。但焦虑的一点在于，它感觉非常像兴奋。我们可以用我们的想法把这种感觉当作能量和动力，而不是当作需要害怕的东西。你知道，在活动开始前，在你需要认识新朋友之前，告诉自己你对这种感觉感到兴奋，你对这种可能性感到兴奋，
and turn that churning stomach, those sweaty palms, all of those physical symptoms, into a good feeling that is excitement, not fear, rather than one that can hold you back. The other way to rewire our cognitive distortions, particularly around the possibility of judgment from others, is to use what I call these so what, or the what next method. So often when we encounter social anxiety, if we immediately jump to the worst case scenario and we let our brains catastrophes and view a situation is considerably worse than it actually is, we really get stuck in that thought pattern. When we catastrophize, we relinquish control over our thoughts and over our lives. So we need to realize that those thoughts can be changed and that they might not be rational. So think back to an experience that maybe caused you to cringe it yourself and feel that shame for a second.
然后把那种翻腾的胃、手心出的汗，所有这些身体症状，都变成一种好的感觉——那是兴奋，而不是恐惧，而不是那种会阻碍你前进的感觉。纠正我们认知扭曲的另一种方法，尤其是围绕着可能受到他人评判的可能性的认知扭曲，就是使用我所说的“那又怎样”或“接下来怎么办”的方法。通常，当我们遇到社交焦虑时，如果我们立即跳到最坏的情况，让大脑将事情灾难化，把情况看得比实际严重得多，我们就会真正陷入这种思维模式中。当我们进行灾难化联想时，我们就放弃了对自己想法和生活的控制。所以我们需要意识到这些想法是可以改变的，它们可能并不理性。所以回想一下曾经可能让你感到难堪并感到羞耻一秒钟的经历。
Let's say you think someone you met didn't like you. Instead of feeling like that's the end of the world, ask yourself, so what? And maybe the answer to that is, well, if they didn't like me, they might think that I'm a bad person. So what? So they may tell their friends, so what? So their friends won't like me. so what? Will the world end? Will you be completely outcast? Will you die? Will the worst case scenario happen? Because that's what your brain's trying to tell you, that this is somehow the worst thing to
比方说，你觉得你遇到的人不喜欢你。不要觉得那是世界末日，而是问自己：那又怎样？也许这个答案是：好吧，如果他们不喜欢我，他们可能会认为我是个坏人。那又怎样？所以他们可能会告诉他们的朋友。那又怎样？所以他们的朋友不会喜欢我。那又怎样？世界会毁灭吗？你会彻底被孤立吗？你会死吗？最坏的情况会发生吗？因为这就是你大脑试图告诉你的，这不知怎么成了你经历过的
ever happen to you, that it means more than it needs to. But when you push back on that thinking, when you ask that feeling, so what, so what if that's what happened, you bring back that sense of control, you realize that the outcome you think will happen, most likely won't. and that it also will never be as bad as you think. Control that cognitive distortion. Try and recognize the ways that your brain is lying to you. And finally, treat your emotions as just friendly creatures trying to help you out, like advice rather than truth.
最糟糕的事情，它比实际需要的意义更重大。但当你回击这种想法，当你对这种感觉发出质问——那又怎样，如果事情真的是那样又怎样——你就找回了那种控制感，你会意识到你认为会发生的结局大多不会发生，而且它也绝不会像你想象的那样糟糕。控制那种认知扭曲。试着认识到大脑欺骗你的方式。最后，把你的情绪当作试图帮助你的友善生灵，当作建议而不是真相来对待。
Because that's really what they are. All that worry and anxiety that we feel from time to time, it may have come from a past situation where we were rejected or we felt excluded or disliked and that event probably really hurt. But the thing is is that we survived it. We're still here. Still breathing. You're listening to this episode.
因为它们确实就是这样。我们时不时感受到的所有担忧和焦虑，可能源于过去的某种情况，在那时我们被拒绝、被排挤或被讨厌，那次事件可能真的让我们很受伤。但关键在于，我们挺过来了。我们依然在这里。依然在呼吸。你正在收听这一集。
But our brain likes to take those past events and apply them to what it thinks are similar scenarios to protect us. However, we can't predict the future. Our brain cannot do that. Just because something happened in the past doesn't increase the likelihood of it happening in the future. And it also does not say anything about who you are. Just like you are not your emotions, you are also not your past. So instead of thinking, I'm embarrassing, I'm awkward, I'm cringe, replace that with, that situation made me feel anxious. That situation was uncomfortable.
但我们的大脑喜欢把那些过去的事件套用到它认为相似的场景中来保护我们。然而，我们无法预测未来。我们的大脑做不到这一点。过去发生过某事并不意味着它在未来发生的可能性会增加。而且它也完全不能说明你是谁。就像你不是你的情绪一样，你也不是你的过去。所以，不要去想“我很尴尬”、“我很笨拙”、“我很丢脸”，而是用这些来代替：“那种情况让我感到焦虑。那种情况很不舒服。”
But that is just an emotion. That is not who I am. I'm going to give you four final affirmations, to repeat to yourselves when you find that you're maybe investing too much in other people's opinions or the fear of a future situation or what could go wrong. Number one, no one is judging you as closely as you are judging yourself. Number two, the opinions of others do not determine your character. Number three, you are never going to be criticised by someone who's doing better than you. number four, you are going to choose to be authentic over being perfect. I know it can be hard to live with those thoughts of what if people don't like me? What if I've humiliated myself? What if I say
但这只是一种情绪。这并不是真正的我。我将给你最后四个肯定语，当发现自己可能过多地投资于别人的意见、对未来情况的恐惧或可能出错了什么时，可以对自己重复这些话。第一，没有人像你自己那样密切地评判你。第二，别人的看法并不能决定你的品格。第三，你永远不会受到一个比你过得更好的人的批评。第四，你要选择做真实的自己，而不是追求完美。我知道，带着“如果人们不喜欢我怎么办”、“如果我让自己出丑了怎么办”、“如果我说错话了怎么办”这些想法生活可能会很艰难，
something wrong? But really true freedom really does begin when we see that those thoughts are not going to change the outcome, right? It's just fear. It's just fear. And fear is just a feeling. It's not the truth, it's not your reality. All you can do is kind of come to every situation with authenticity, confidence, kindness towards other people, and I think that most of the time that is reciprocated. And once again, if they don't like you, that is such a disappointment for them. That is such a loss because you are the type of person who will elevate their life, the way that you elevate your own and those around you. And you are sure of that and you know that about yourself and you know that whatever they think about you, that is not going to change that truth.
但真正彻底的自由确实始于我们认识到这些想法并不会改变结果，对吧？这只是恐惧。这只是恐惧。而恐惧只是一种感觉。它不是真相，也不是你的现实。你所能做的，就是带着真实、自信和对其他人的善意去面对每一种情况，而且我认为大多数时候这都会得到回报。再说一次，如果他们不喜欢你，那是他们巨大的遗憾。那是他们巨大的损失，因为你是那种能够提升他们生活品质的人，就像你提升自己周围人的一样。你对此深信不疑，你很清楚这一点，你知道无论他们对你有什么看法，都无法改变这个真相。
So I think that's all we have time for today, a little brief episode on social anxiety. And I hope that if this is something you're struggling with, that you learn some important skills, but also a deeper knowledge of why this might be going on, what kind of cognitive distortions are really causing this. It's also something I deal with. I totally understand what it feels like to sometimes almost feel sick, thinking about having to interact with other people and really worrying about how it's going to turn out. But sometimes you just got to feel the fear and do it anyways.
我想这就是我们今天的全部时间了，这是一个关于社交焦虑的简短节目。我希望如果这是你正在挣扎的事情，你能学到一些重要的技巧，以及更深入地了解这背后可能的原因，究竟是什么样的认知扭曲真正导致了这一切。这也是我一直在处理的事情。我完全理解那种想到要与其他人互动就几乎感到恶心，并且真的很担心结果会怎样的感觉。但有时你只需要带着恐惧去把事情做了。
That's something we say on the show all the time. So hopefully that has resonated with you in some way or another. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you're listening right now. Follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you have some thoughts on this episode, if you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to share what's on your mind. I love building that community over there and hearing what's going on in your lives. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all?
这是我们在节目中经常说的一句话。所以希望这能在某种程度上引起你的共鸣。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。在Instagram上关注我们，账号是 That Psychology Podcast。如果你对这一集有什么想法，如果你有节目的建议，或者只是想分享你的心事。我很喜欢在那边建立社区，倾听你们生活中的点滴。一如既往，我们下周将带着新的一集回归。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a license professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《学得艰难》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都并不真正安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学得艰难》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，还有迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在IHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。百分之二。这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
而在有自动扶梯可用的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，精神韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即TWO%。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过，
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们将事情掌握在自己手中。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是这样说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart广播应用、Apple Podcasts、
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed he'll be. Amen. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证他会。阿门。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。